This concludes the 203.03 atmospheric lighting course
for Unreal Engine 5.6.
In this course, we explored the fundamentals
of working with and manipulating volumetric fog.
We also covered how to utilize god rays, fog cards,
and implement localized fog volumes
to add depth to our level.
We briefly covered the basics of using a post-processing volume
and creating a basic post-processing material that
could be added to a post-processing volume
for further artistic effect and control.
Finally, we wrapped up the class with a few hands-on examples
of lighting an interior scene, and we briefly
covered the key concepts for using megalites.
Thanks for watching.